uzbek
and c4 knight f6 knight is the e5 uh-huh
okay
very very interesting d4 again
again
same system and the as against magnus
button
yeah just making sure not to allow
bishop g4
a5 make sure to save his bishop as well
we have seen before that white was
playing ac knight a4 before knight a4
in that game so yeah white stopped
bishop g4 but
it came at a cost of not
getting to black's bishop
these structures once again i struggle
understanding bishop e3 if you take fe
i guess it's comfortable for white with
this poor mess in the center but it's
very hard for me to figure out what goes
where
yeah young thick stakes
yeah it feels like in italian but uh in
the italian the bishop is on c4 and the
pawn is on c2
it seems to me like jani is exactly
playing the same style yeah 97 knight g6
3d1 knight h4 also the typical way of
playing this stuff
thing is always the opponent h6 in the
italians you want your pawn on h7 if you
take on e3 because then you have much
more
flexibility with going knight g6 and so
on but
here the bomb was already on h6
so he has to live with this
knight g6 knight of five and i quite
like white's position here like i guess
you take and then ef knight back to e7
but it feels like why there's some more
space in freedom yeah white has some
space and some possibilities on the king
side
so c6 going for d5 looks like a more
natural way so after queen gc however
black
can't really tolerate it and look takes
oh interesting i thought ponte was
coming by once again
i mean
somehow the bishop on itu i don't see so
much benefit of of luca in italian it's
the typical stuff and
with the bishop on c for putting
pressure on the f7 pawn here it's a bit
counter-intuitive
yeah some bishop h5 in some lines but
it's not it's not coming yet yeah
yeah i don't think that one
queen h4 maybe
but but look at this i mean
up on the clock
up on the clock against jan
it's not called down to satoru
with h4
um
i guess you take
well but i mean i'm not sure that
psychologically you want to take yeah
you you have this uh strange pawn
structure
i i feel like
so what do you do quit h2
yeah maybe queen h2
this is very strange
this is very strange but i guess black
wants to go g6 king g7
is perfect
is the typical
whenever you feel like uh this has
happened you feel like you're starting
to play for a window because long-term
these pawns can be a little can be a
little shaky yeah but now this knight g5
is a very concrete move because some
h496 bishop g4 ideas are there i don't
like this yeah not a fanny though i
thought just g6 and slowly yeah
absolutely i mean just g6 king g7 and
super happy and now you suddenly created
three problems for yourself knight c5
runs into d4 and white might be anywhere
going for d4 and
opening up the d file look f7 is a
threat now so you have to do something
yes
yeah you have to move
no this is a c7 but it's a very ugly
move of course
yeah no this knight g5 was just uh very
very unfortunate
because it fell yeah like just g6 king
g7 and then you can start thinking about
ways to be better well you know
wow but even concrete problems knight b6
knight d7 and hitting on f7 so there are
even concrete problems white hat black
hat too weakened even further with f6
this looks horrible now
maybe 64 but okay it's still a solid
opponent yeah and 96 that is luke a6
yeah that is the basic this is important
this this balancing this knight but yeah
white breaks with d4 before
it feels like this is now very very
unpleasant
before you do b5 um that might be six
yeah
yeah look at the eight three eight the
white can double on the default let's
see why it will double yeah and then how
long you can hold on to this
how long you can hold on to this
also once again his abductor of speed is
amazing no natural moves he just doesn't
doubt he's just making them it's
just very very good yeah
amazing yeah i mean he's a fantastic
technician he he likes all these type of
positions and whenever he gets a target
he's super dangerous yeah
yeah it feels like
i don't need to
of course it's terrible because it opens
the c file
but i'm just very nervous and i want to
make yeah b5 played yeah i mean it's a
nervous move you can't wait you can you
know it's bad it can't be good but what
else you have to hope for something cb
played
wow i'm more and more impressed with the
guy cb knight b5 yeah because cb that
was knight b6
wasn't great either
yeah but no
this is falling apart roxy one
ah but roxy one
copy doesn't approve maybe some hope
yeah i mean because i was very afraid of
some knight b6 jump because now white's
knight is stuck on a4 and you can't keep
my knight from from b5 this is some
chance to yeah yeah
dude back in business
still very unpleasant and with only 37
seconds
not the type of guy who is used to this
uh 960. this is the thing
now so why possession
but okay he understands
the moment is passed so he regroups king
f7
yeah discovering the e6 square
and
maybe after the trade of knights black
will be able to play some d6 d5
somewhere if if necessary
sort of spending his time here as well
plays h5 feels like he's drifting like
h5 feels better i mean he missed the
momentum yeah
there was there was a moment for sure
but now the question is what can uh
i mean jan has to keep the speed yeah
looks like it would be five this is
exactly what i felt like if white plays
some look cdc then black can play d5
bishop e2 played
some ed rock g5 he won't sell it
no no
i think he will not
not change the pawn structure i mean
yeah with d5 he can change the pawn
structure but
what is it
is so fast sporting stuff
yeah and this king is running into some
look i mean some mating net as well
drama
yeah and bishop takes yeah because
knight f5 would be would have been good
takes i guess
yeah and the problem is that e4 runs
into king f4 yeah that's why jan had to
play this king g5 but
rupees three
king h5 rookie five king g6 what is this
okay at least at least young survived
and uh the clock plays a big low now
d6 wow very dry again
of course very annoying
yeah e4 d7
king f7 check
king g6 back
look e7
pardon
for the system
of d6 look f7 f7
this looks like a winner
v8 take more pawns
but the clock is still ticking
yeah clock is ticking now whiter than
this eight rookie five
king f5 oh he missed it rookie five and
for roxy4 was checking
luke takes b2
okay five seconds nice very nervous rook
g8
i'm not to look at rook g5 h3 rook h7
wow yeah but okay
the players are not completely
look d6 check king if i looked in what
wow
young's gonna make a draw yeah like
i don't know because each one is still
at making that
look this thick h2 can't take the pawn
d8
yep
yeah that's it
wow
that's it
what a drama
yeah congratulations for no dear back
amazing i mean amazing speed yeah